hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde ihr seht schon das hier
ist kein Vlog keine reaction keine
Ahnung was denn ich spiele mal wieder
Minecraft und ihr seht auch schon äh das
ist ein bisschen was anderes es ist ich
bin hier nicht in irgendeiner Welt
sondern hier vorne haben wir diesen
Kapitän von oh kannst du interact nee
das machen wir noch nicht das hier ist
auf jeden Fall der Captain von dem
Spongebob Intro weil wir tatsächlich
heute die Spongebob DLCs meistern werden
und das war eigentlich allein sondern
mit
dem Special guess craft Heiko hallo
hallo wir zwei süßen machen heute drei
Herausforderungen im neuen Spongebob DLC
was ist jetzt tatsächlich gibt auf dem
Minecraft Marktplatz also könnt ihr euch
gerne runterladen ihr findet alle Infos
dazu in der Videobeschreibung es kommt
tatsächlich die Tage auch noch mal ein
zweites Video mit einem anderen special
Geld kann ich schon mal in den
Kommentaren raten mehr sein wird nicht
du weil mit dir mache
wir machen heute auf jeden Fall die
Aufgaben von Thaddäus Patrick und Mister
krabs so noch mehr Spongebob Inhalte
schaut unbedingt auch auf dem Spongebob
YouTube Kanal vorbei ganze folgen könnt
ihr natürlich auf Super RTL und
Nickelodeon sehen und ich würde sagen
wollen wir einfach mal punchen uns unter
Action hier bist du bereit ich bin
bereit
ich schlage einfach mal ein Ei Captain
sagt auf jeden Fall geht's jetzt los oh
oh mein Gott
das sieht ultra krass aus was
ich mich immer schon gefragt habe warum
hat Spongebob an seine Ananas oben einen
Schornstein das ergibt überhaupt keinen
Sinn das stimmt so so plötzlich so ein
Lagerfeuer so unter Wasser machen oder
so aber ey wie viel Liebe zum Detail ist
das hier bitte also wenn ihr euch das
kauft dann habt ihr halt dieses Pack
Blabla ihr braucht natürlich Minecraft
allerdings seht ihr schon ey guck mal da
ist eine Miesmuschel hier vorne haben
wir die haben Thaddäus hier vorne wir
haben hier Spongebob da vorne ist das
Haus von Patrick da gehen wir gleich
auch noch hin wir machen ja heute
Patrick Thaddäus und Mister krass und da
würde ich sagen lassen wir Spongebob
erstmal aus und vor und ich schon direkt
eigentlich ganz gerne mit ihm
hintergehen möchte guck mal seine Nase
er sieht so süß aus er freut sich
richtig dass wir hier sind ich will mich
erstmal ehrlich gesagt gerade ein
bisschen umgucken wenn wir überall auch
so ach nee trocknet Spongebob first
steht okay wir sollen zu Spongebob reden
strange looking fish are you from rock
bottom you must be visiting Bikini
Bottom for the big best day ever
celebration anscheinend feiern die heute
irgendwas er will all seinen Freunden
heute den besten Tag der Welt machen und
das inkludiert Patrick Thaddäus Mr krabs
Sandy misses Puff und Plankton also
sechs Leute wir haben tatsächlich dem
DLC hier sechs Herausforderungen die wir
machen werden wie gesagt heute drei die
Tage auch noch mal drei und wir können
auch gar nicht mit nein antworten wir
haben nur jetzt absolutely oder let's do
it von daher würde ich sagen einfach
sagen jetzt perfekt whenever your ready
let's get out there make today the best
day ever also wir sind glaube ich bereit
oder oh
wir müssen Quallenfischen oder was was
müssen wir machen aber können wir die
direkt fangen oder ich weiß es nicht
viel zu schnell wieso verfolgt Spongebob
dich eigentlich
der wollte mit ich war vielleicht mehr
am Ziel aber warum will der die
hinterher das ist sehr gute Frage ich
bin dem scheiß egal
da steht
oh mein Gott
wir laufen jetzt auf jeden Fall mal
rüber zu Thaddäus und Fragen mal ob wir
ihm vielleicht irgendwie helfen können
er sagt nämlich
[Musik]
wir wollen ja auch helfen bei Deinem
besten Tag heute can you play any
instruments
Mayonnaise also Thaddäus hat ein Konzert
und wir müssen ihm dabei helfen seine
Klarinette zusammenzubauen also let's go
würde ich sagen
wir müssen auf jeden Fall Dinge finden
um seine Klarinette zusammenzubauen denn
wir alle wissen ja dass der Deus es
unfassbar doll lieb Klarinette zu
spielen
die riesig ist denn dieses Haus von ihm
dass die Tür noch draußen nee und ist
ein Wohnzimmer ey wir brauchen
irgendwelche Sachen um eine Klarinette
zu bauen hier ist eine Kiste aha Mario
Nese
ja das wolltest du doch ist doch perfekt
ja geil
guck mal hier ist auch noch eine können
wir auch noch mal eben rausnehmen und
jetzt können wir theoretisch das ganze
craften ich habe alles doppelt das heißt
ich könnte dir einfach die Hälfte der
Sachen einfach mal eben kurz
rüberschmeißen kannst du dir vielleicht
auch eine craften die links am Rand
sehen wir dass wir eine Klarinette
craften können mit den Dingen die wir
haben von daher können wir uns mal die
Klarinette habt sie in der Hand Thaddäus
brauchst du die irgendwie what is take
you Salon have you fallen Instrumente
played yes look at you look at the
downtown oh okay wir gehen jetzt
Downtown hast du deine Klarinette fertig
ich habe alles da oh perfekt Gott
no joke mit wie viel Liebe oh mein Gott
ist das hier nicht der der in dieser
einen Nachrichtensendung da irgendwie
durch oder oder bin ich blöd
doch ey das sind alles Charaktere die
schon mal bei Spongebob gab hey no job
ich hätte nicht gedacht
da hinten ist auch noch diese Fahrschule
von Mrs paff einfach aber gut wir müssen
auf jeden Fall jetzt ein Konzert spielen
um Siegbert Schnösel zu besiegen ich
kann bloß
so was machst du denn hier
ich wollte nur zusehen wie du versagt
Soundcheck let's start playing and get
wombt ab okay wir sollen anfangen zu
spielen
[Musik]
okay wir müssen glaube ich unten zehn
von zehn zum Tanzen bringen so wie ich
das jetzt richtig erkenne von da würde
ich sagen laufen wir mal hier vorne
rüber wenn ich sie jetzt hier Bespiele
ist das dann sieben von zehn
nee dann hat sie anscheinend schon
getagt
sehr gut dann gehe ich noch mal hier
vorne zu dem Kollegen hier hallo
neun von zehn und wenn das hier voll ist
haben wir vielleicht schon die zehn von
zehn voll perfekt talk to Squid watch
steht jetzt also zu Thaddäus reden äh
erscheint hier zu sagen dass wir
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so schlecht
sind im spielen und er meint wir sind
fertig für die Performance in der
äußerstage also ich würde sagen let's go
dann äh teleportieren wir uns wieder
rüber und sind jetzt auf dem Konzert
okay macht Thaddäus fängt er jetzt an
oder soll ich noch mal mit ihm reden
this is it let's go on stage and play
the best concent Bikini Bottom has ever
seen okay let's go auf geht's 3 2 1 los
[Musik]
also die Dance Moves von den ganzen
Fischen sind auf jeden Fall ausbaufähig
nee der Bademeister der große
Challenge haben wir geschafft glaube ich
wir würde ich sagen machen direkt weiter
mit der nächsten Aufgabe von heute der
zweiten von den drei und zwar hatten mit
Patrick zu tun hier vorne wir haben uns
ja vorhin schon sein Haus kurz angeguckt
allerdings hat Patrick auch was für uns
zu tun er sagte nämlich auch dass wir
Spongebob neue Freund sind blablabla und
wir sollen ihm helfen in äh bei seinem
new ride opening at Glow world und der
will unbedingt mit uns diese Achterbahn
fahren wir helfen natürlich auch Patrick
bei seinem großen Wunsch einmal das äh
die neuen Freizeitpark hier zu erleben
einmal eine Runde fahren zu dürfen weil
der Freizeitpark hat einfach noch nicht
fertiggestellt ist unsere Aufgabe in
diesem riesigen wir war Freizeitpark ist
es jetzt auf jeden Fall Materialien
zusammen zu suchen um diesen
Freizeitpark fertig zu stellen patrick
hat ihn Ausrufezeichen
Deal wir sind drin ich habe unsere
eingeholt oh guck mal auch immer diese
Animation zwischendrin und das Ding
müssen wir aufbauen das wird
Zeit dauern
also wir sollten paar Kisten suchen hier
vorne ist direkt die erste da haben wir
ganz viele stilblöcke drin also
Stahlblöcke
[Musik]
geht einfach nicht weg aber vielleicht
weil du da bist ne die verfolgen
hey Sam Trottel
aber er hilft uns
mal weg so danke schön
so Freunde jetzt gesehen wir haben hier
alle möglichen Support Dinger
zusammengebaut so dass die Achterbahn
von der Statiker natürlich auch fahren
kann von da klicken wir jetzt hier auch
noch mal mit rechtsklick drauf und wir
haben tatsächlich den letzten Support
auch fertiggestellt ist Spongebob hat
einen Fragezeichen über Kopf und 12
Sekunden später sehen wir wahrscheinlich
wieder eine Animation wie wir nämlich
alles fertiggestellt haben Patrick's
Traum haben wir auch in Erfüllung
gebracht und wir werden jetzt mit ihm
eine Achterbahnfahrt machen können nur
wenige Minuten später
es wäre richtig nice und Sache da noch
so ein Foto von uns gehabt von uns allen
was ist deine lieblings Spongebob Folge
mit Patrick
boah
probably die Mayonnaise Geschichte oder
ich ich finde dieses also die krasseste
Folge so mit Patrick und SpongeBob
fahren ich war die wo die den Bus
verpasst haben weißt du
in Rock Bottom da hinten landen und dann
nehme ich den falschen Bus eingestiegen
sind und dann mit der handschuhwelt und
so diesen ganz Fischen die
auch ein bisschen Angst bin ich ganz
ehrlich
wir müssen zurück nach Bikini
wo sind wir eigentlich hier
Patrick haben wir auf jeden Fall
geholfen seinen Traum in Erfüllung zu
bringen indem er diese neuen
Rollercoaster da gefahren ist wir laufen
jetzt allerdings und dafür haben wir
auch die Karte und sehen da genau wo wir
uns gerade befinden rüber zur großen
Krabbe denn was wäre Spongebob ohne Mr
krabs vor allem auch Plankton da gibt es
auch noch ein Minispiel die müssen wir
auch seinen besten Tag ever ähm möglich
machen allerdings soll es heute nicht um
Plankton gehen seine komische Roboter
Freundin da sondern nur Mr krabs und was
verbindet man Minister krabs richtig
Burger und Geld von daher müssen wir Mr
krabs heute dabei helfen ganz ganz viel
Kohle zu verdienen denn ganz viele Busse
mit Fischen werden angekommen die wollen
alle Burger haben kennt ihr vielleicht
aus der ersten Folge Spongebob die es
überhaupt
Gabeln was sollen
wir sehen schon die ersten Busse kommen
an und wir müssen die ganzen jetzt mit
Bürgern beliefern ich habe hier pirate
of Burgers die werde ich jetzt einfach
mal hier hinstellen ich werde hier
welche hinstellen wenn ich hier vorne
welche hinstellen und hier und jetzt
wieder zurück da hinten drüber was ist
das hier place of partouler was ist denn
das gravity Patty Tray also kannst du
das Werfen auf die einfach ab ja also
ich stell das hier drauf einfach ich
dachte so richtig schön Restaurant ach
das kann man kann so richtig zielen auch
auf die geil
hey die Essen hier alles weg ne die
fressen so viel gerade ja muss das
erstmal hier die Tische neu belegen oh
das ist doch ey wenn noch eine Welle
danach kommen ne dann weiß er gar nicht
wie wir das hier bewältigen sollen das
ist einfach
hinten im Büro nein
dürfen nur nicht an die Kasse kommen und
noch ich spiele Klarinette ich spiel
Klarinette vielleicht gehen die dann
morgen sie gehen sie gehen aber nur ein
paar oh nein oh nein weiter sind die
Jahre später okay ich glaube das wird
das war's das war's new heißt Gott 1289
okay die sind bedient sie haben die
krasse Krabbe auseinander genommen aber
Mr krabs hat eine nein den Berg voll
Kohle na hör mal
Mister krabs
Mr Kramps bedankt sich auf jeden Fall
bei uns wir klicken auf Schuhe
teleportiert uns nie wir sehen sogar
noch einen ganz kurzen Animation hier ah
nee warte
ich habe es neu gestartet
da wir jetzt allerdings auch Mr krabs
geholfen haben diesen Tag zu seinem
besten Tag aller Zeiten zu machen hier
in Bikini Bottom würde ich sagen dass
wir an der Stelle das heutige Video auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde wenn Euch
das hier gefallen hat diese Kooperation
die mit SpongeBob Minecraft dann lasst
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter diesem
Video da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen castcrafter aka Heiko
selbstverständlich unten in der
Beschreibung verlinkt Spongebob
natürlich auch das ganze DLC könnt ihr
euch jetzt runterladen auf dem auf dem
Minecraft Marktplatz und es gibt noch
weitere Minigames werden wie die Tage
spielen für noch mehr Spongebob Inhalte
schaut unbedingt auf dem Spongebob
YouTube Kanal vorbei ganze folgen könnt
ihr natürlich auch Super RTL und
Nickelodeon sehen und du hast die
letzten fünf Worte
es war das schönste Tag der beste Tag
den ich jemals hatte und ich hoffe alle
anderen auch das waren mehr als fünf
Worte aber ist in Ordnung ciao